[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en dehors des aficionados du scrabble
j'ai vérifié 1 ça fait soixante quinze
points en mot compte triple combien
parmi vous ce matin ont pensé à l'immuno
cancérologie mille noms sans nom à l'e10
un nom mais louis michel la famille ça
marche pas désolé d'en bal yen a qu'une
c'est moi parce que l'immuno
cancérologie c'est une chose importante
c'est une chose sérieuse
d'ailleurs pour vous en parler j'ai
enfilé ma blouse de professeur
d'immunologie à la faculté de médecine
chef du service d'immunologie du chu de
rennes et directrice de l'unité de
recherche inserm u 1236
microenvironnement différenciation
cellulaire immunologie et cancer eh oui
petit clin d'oeil toutes les femmes qui
portent des blues ne sont pas infirmière
ou de laborantine
dans immuno cancérologie il ya
immunologie l'étude du système
immunitaire
le système qui vous des francs contre
les virus les bactéries qui vous colle
des allergies et accessoirement qui vous
permet de faire des bébés
non messieurs du premier rang je parle
pas de la première demi heure
enfin les trois premières minutes
parfois un an je vous parle mesdames des
neuf mois qui suivent ceux où à moins de
vous être reproduit avec votre frère
jumeau ce que je ne vous souhaite pas
vous tolérez un foetus qui est un alien
totalement incompatible avec vous d'un
point de vue immunologique au moins
l'immunologie donc et dans immuno
cancérologie il ya aussi cancérologie
parce que oui aujourd'hui je vais vous
parler du cancer une maladie qui vous
concerne tous alors je pourrais vous
parler des facteurs de risque du cancer
vous rappeler que le tabac est la
première cause de cancer ce qui est vrai
ou alors que les pesticides à odos
totalement chez les agriculteurs
favorise le risque de certains cancers
ce qui est vrai aussi
vive les salades d'intérieur et donc que
le cancer est un véritable enjeu de
santé publique mais non il ne s'agira
pas ici aujourd'hui d'une vision
sociétale du cancer je pourrais aussi
vous expliquer les différences
génétiques qui existent entre les
différents types de cancers ou bien au
sein d'un même type de cancer entre les
différents patients ou encore pour un
même malade entre sa tumeur primitive et
sa métastases
mais non il ne s'agira pas non plus un
cours sur la génétique du cancer non si
je suis là ici aujourd'hui c'est pour
vous parler du réseau extrêmement
intriqués d'interaction qui se développe
entre d'une part les cellules tumorales
et d'autre part les cellules normales
notamment immunitaire qu'il en soit ce
dialogue favorise la croissance de la
tumeur et sait se forment ce qu'on
appelle la niche tumorales
eh oui si je suis ici aujourd'hui c'est
bien pour vous parler d'immuno
cancérologie pas de chance mais avant ça
un bref petit retour en arrière sur ce
qu'on pourrait appeler la mode en
sciences et en fait en sciences comme
ailleurs la mode c'est plus tellement la
blouse la théorie selon laquelle notre
système immunitaire nous protège contre
le cancer
également appelée théorie de l'immuno
surveillance date en fait du début du
20e siècle
elle repose sur l'idée qu'une cellule
cancéreuse est reconnu par le système
immunitaire comme différente des
cellules normales genre contrôles
d'identité montrez moi vos papiers et
qu'elle va être détruite par ce système
immunitaire mais l'échec dans les années
70 80 des stratégies de vaccination anti
cancer alors même qu'on était capable de
recruter au sein des tumeurs
un grand nombre de ces gendarmes système
immunitaire mais qu'ils étaient arrive
avérée totalement incompétent a conduit
à l'abandon
le désintérêt complet pour ces approches
à la fois d'un point de vue scientifique
et financier adieu l'immuno cancérologie
vive les thérapies ciblées en effet au
même moment où ont lieu les progrès
incroyables du séquençage à haut débit
qui permet de lire en un temps record la
totalité du code génétique d'une cellule
et même de savoir tout ce qu'elle
produit à raison d 1
je vous arrête tout de suite deux
facettes on le fait en plusieurs heures
ce n'est pas si rapide que ça il n'y a
que dans les experts qu'un type agitant
titube fait tourner son super méga
logiciel ou en 12 secondes apparaît la
photo du suspect qui n'est autre que le
faux jardinier amont de la victime
les chercheurs ont alors essayé
d'identifier parmi ces altérations
génétiques lesquels étaient vraiment
responsable du cancer soit parce
qu'elles favorisaient la prolifération
la multiplication des cellules tumorales
soit parce qu'elles bloquaient leur mort
en parallèle bien sûr on l'a cherché à
cibler ces altérations génétiques par
des petites molécules chimiques c'est l
essor des thérapies ciblées et
finalement ça n'est que très récemment
que les super brillant synology ceux des
cancers et les super brillant généticien
les cancers se sont dits groupons nous
et demain décrétons le salut commun en
effet il venait de se rendre compte
d'une évidence plus de cellules
tumorales et anormale d'un point de vue
génétique plus elle a de chances d'être
vu et reconnu par le système immunitaire
et donc potentiellement détruites
il était temps de travailler ensemble
en plus pendant cette période les
illogismes ont découvert que la niche
tumorales le système immunitaire qui
infiltrent les tumeurs est constitué
d'une association de bons de brut et de
truands les bons les gentils on veut ce
sont les cellules immunitaires anti
tumorale et en particulier celle qu'on
appelle les lymphocytes tueurs ou
cytotoxiques
pour être efficace il faut qu'ils soient
nombreux
c'est un peu comme en démocratie faut
être nombreux pour faire entendre sa
voix si vous voyez ce que je veux dire
mais il faut aussi qu'il soit capable de
reconnaître spécifiquement la tumeur le
suspect ça c'est le premier facteur
limitant dans beaucoup de cas notamment
lorsque la tumeur possède beaucoup
d'altération génétique
ces paramètres sont remplies et pourtant
elle n'est pas détruite pourquoi parce
que ses gentils sont comme souvent dans
la vraie vie un peu comment dire est
gentil gentil quoi un peu
mou du genou et ça c'est dû au fait que
la cellule cancéreuse exprima sa surface
pour leur échapper
des molécules freins qui les bloque il
faut donc réactivé réveiller ces gentils
gendarmes
et pour ça on dispose d'une nouvelle
classe de médicaments qui sont des
anticorps levant ses freins alors comme
au pays de candy
il y a les gentils et il y a les
méchants et les méchants ils sont super
efficace super tordus ce sont de vrais
psychopathes
on en distingue deux grandes catégories
les premiers vont directement stimuler
les cellules tumorales les seconds vont
favoriser la construction
l'organisation de la niche par exemple
ils peuvent favoriser la formation de
nouveaux vaisseaux sanguins ou bien ils
vont bloquer de façon active les gentils
gendarmes en les rendant tout mou comme
on l'a vu précédemment
on trouve dans cette catégorie par
exemple les lymphocytes t régulateurs et
on dispose aujourd'hui doivent attendre
de stratégie qui vise à les détruire
enfin comme dans tout bon western il y a
les truands des mecs potentiellement
sympa mais en fait bien sournois et qui
peuvent faire le mal on retrouve là par
exemple les macrophages associés aux
tumeurs alors eux ils peuvent manger les
cellules du mois est ca c est bien mais
ils peuvent aussi produire des facteurs
pro tumoraux et ça c'est nettement moins
bien
alors là l'objectif c'est de les
rééduquer de les ramener dans le droit
chemin
en gros de transformer les méchants en
gentil dans la très chouette unité
inserm
je dirige lui 1236 eh bien on
s'intéresse à ces différents types de
cellules à la façon dont elles
dialoguent entre elles dont elle évolue
avec la tumeur dont elles s'organisent
en écosystèmes dans un type particulier
de tumeur qu'on appelle les lymphome ou
tumeurs des ganglions
qui est un excellent modèle de niche
tumorales plein de bons de brut et de
truands ainsi on a pu démontrer
récemment qu'une des altérations
génétiques les plus fréquentes empêche
les cellules tumorales de produire un
facteur antitumorale qu'on appelle hvm
la perte d'âge même et puissamment pro
tumorales parce qu'elle va à la fois
activée directement les cellules
cancéreuses mais aussi favoriser les
supers méchants qui vont booster les
tumeurs et favoriser la construction de
la niche trop balèze dans ces conditions
on a carrément fait appel aux raids des
cellules cytotoxique super efficace et
super spécifique de la tumeur alors le
raid un juge vous rappelle c'est
l'équipe qui ressemble peut-être à brad
pitt ou george clooney
sauf qu'en fait on n'en sait rien parce
qu'ils ont sont toujours masqué quoi
alors on a fait un peu pareil dans les
cellules ses eaux toxiques
on a introduit subrepticement la
molécule à genève on a réintroduit le
tout dans des souris malades et les
cellules tueuses ont pu à la fois
détruire la tumeur et en reléguant du
hvm inhiber les supers méchants trop
fort alors pourquoi cet après midi je
suis venu vous parler d'immuno
cancérologie alors que pour la plupart
d'entre vous heureusement vous
développerez jamais de lymphome
alors que pour la totalité d'entre vous
vous ne vous étiez jamais posé la
question de la niche tumorales ceux qui
ne te l'ont bien est un tort alors tout
d'abord peut-être pour vous rendre un
peu moins idiot enfin ce qui me semble
déjà être un objectif fort louable non
non non en fait c'est pas ça mais l'idée
c'est que alors que les altérations
génétiques sont spécifiques de chaque
cancer
ces mécanismes d'interaction entre les
cellules cancéreuses et leurs niches
sont communs à tous les cancers et
l'heure de leur connaissance naissent de
nouvelles stratégies thérapeutiques qui
sont potentiellement efficace dans tous
les cancers
les perspectives sont immenses les
premiers résultats passionnants mais le
coût extrêmement élevé de ces
thérapeutiques va impacter l'ensemble de
notre système de santé
donc en fait oui aujourd'hui je suis
aussi venu vous parler d'une question
sociétale celle de savoir ce que vous
voulez faire de votre système de santé
de ce que vous voulez faire d'autres
systèmes de recherche
c'est une question qui ne concerne pas
une 10 cents ou mille personnes ici mais
qui nous concerne tous je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]